girls empowerment Middle School known as
gems is the first all-girls Charter
School in Las Vegas and the focus there
is stem education but more importantly
turning young teens into leaders
in our one of our Community Pride
recipients and they're also supported by
our community party Partners Heather
Mills explains why this school is so
unique
um I feel good I really do not want to
leave but I know there's a lot in my
future that you know I can't wait to see
and see where it takes me we first met
Kobe last year she had just transferred
here as a seventh grader now a year
older and wiser this young woman is
ready to tackle what's next because of
the foundation she received here at
school there's a class here called
empowerment and the teacher she really
teaches you how to be yourself how to
respect yourself it's really helpful how
can you speak your mind without
sabotaging your friendship students at
gems girls empowerment Middle School get
to focus on core subjects with an
emphasis on stem education without the
distraction of boys their leadership
skills are improved they are more open
to be you know sharing up sharing their
thoughts and ideas you know they feel
more empowered that way and all of this
leads to academic achievement academic
success Ira Salisbury teaches health
that gems where movement starts the
class and inspires productivity on this
day I got to join in
Ms Salisbury is breaking down barriers
with encouragement and enthusiasm they
come in with these problems already so
we have to try to maneuver through that
to get so we can educate but once we get
all of that out the way and we have seen
it here they are so much better the
small classes help with that I do think
because it is a small school that the
teachers have a better connection with
all the kids and that does help you know
with the encouragement gems is tuition
free supporting students both
financially academically and emotionally
we put everything into our girls and we
can see the change we can see it the
girls see it themselves too everyone's
always in a good mood and they're always
boosting your confidence and making you
feel good about yourself so I definitely
think that's a plus for young girls who
do want to come to this school it's just
amazing
that's all I can say simply amazing
Heather Mills eight news now